Ronald I've done it I found your
assistant and he's dope his name is
jean-ralphio jean-ralphio
Big T Mr Swanson two things one it is an
absolute honor to meet you two who is
that hot intern chick out there because
honestly
uh take a seat right here we go
so John ralphio you got him right here
leave a message after the beat why do I
want you as my assistant
starters access to the illest club and
that's just for starters I will work for
you I will be on you 24 7. I'll be like
your family I'm here when you get here
in the morning sure enough I'll be there
tucking you into bed at night don't
worry it's not gay do we have questions
I think our only question is uh when can
you start right now let's do it
thank you for coming in we will talk
cool I feel good about this I know you
can hit me up on Facebook anytime day or
night you know that right take care
buddy boom
so what do you think of your new
assistant
I want to punch you in the face so bad
right now what will you do me one final
kindness
will you pretend to be my wife for an
insurance scam but then we fall in love
for real take me there
boom
who are you this is Ben he's here to
help us with the paperwork Ben is that
your real name yes or you could do
better than that I'm gonna help you out
right now your name is Angelo Angelo
thank you so much for coming out get a
thicker tie it looks weird on you makes
your head look like a fish secondly I
don't know where the paperwork is but
when you find it can you take care of it
for us we don't have any pens because
we're afraid it's gonna leak in our
shirts lastly I hate the name Angelo
I'ma switch it up for you right now your
new nickname is
jello shots everything about that Jay
shot do we have questions yeah where are
we all right Ben if you need anything
one of these models that we pay to hang
around here will grab it for you
meantime we're gonna be playing video
games tweeting in high scores
what are those shrimp
oh my God yeah I know I know I know hey
Sean ralphio how's it going it's going
good I'm actually right here for an
appointment getting a Brazilian by the
way there's a woman over there that is
unbelievable her name is Kim when she
rips it off she smiles and it makes you
feel things throw my name I get a
referral discount if you don't mind
I heard somebody resigned in disgrace my
question to you is how you making that
paper oh yeah well I've interviewed
around uh but I'm actually about to take
a job doing in-house accounting for an
accounting firm
I almost fell asleep during this
sentence okay let me get this right you
would be an accountant
for accountants yeah so at this
accounting firm you would have the
boring job
are you nuts this is probably the first
time you've had off since you've been
Kid President true or false
true why don't you use that time and go
after one of your passions like model
trains or like or toy gandalfs or
something
while you jump straight to model trains
I mean
it's accurate I'm going to tell you
something that I once heard from a very
very smart woman named Kim the lady who
waxes you she told me if you don't love
what you do
what am I doing
and she ripped the hair for my b-hole
time to start a casino
oh my God
you're John Rafael's dad you're the one
that's trying to put me out of business
wow look at that Mr Haverford you track
me down looks like you're Detective
skills are a lot better than your tween
high-end fashion rental skills and Chris
can we have the room please no you
certainly cannot Dr saberstein why are
you doing this would it ever do to you
you know exactly why I'm doing this you
destroyed my family first you screwed my
son out of your business and then you
stole my daughter's virginity
[Laughter]
wait you're serious deadly serious
according to my daughter you broke her
heart then you smashed up her BMW I had
to buy her a new one so she could drive
to Divinity School let me tell you
something Mister you attack a saperstein
you face my wrath be so sure about this
tiny Tom that I will Crush you like the
bug you are
and there it is the heartbeat hold up my
dad said that yeah John ralphiel he told
me that I had screwed you out of my
business so he was gonna screw me back
any idea why he'd believe such a thing
that is so weird
that is so uh you know what honestly I
don't think about it this may be it I
actually told him that rent a swag was
my idea and that you had stole it from
me why would you say that because my dad
has always writing me for never having a
job and I just didn't want to show that
I blew it again
oh and I don't know if this is relevant
but but I told him that you made me sign
up for a bunch of credit cards and then
Max them out by buying a legal white
Jaguar fur coats that's probably not
relevant though I don't know all this
lying about me stops now this is my life
please one of you has to tell him the
truth
oh okay fine you know what
I'm gonna do the unthinkable
I'm gonna have a short honest
conversation with my father thank you
thank you all for coming and let me just
say how truly deeply Trill it is to be
standing in this dope ass conference
room and dressing a group of people in a
business meeting it's really a dream
come true uh right now I want to turn
the floor over to John ralphia who has
something to say
Tom
lawyer guy
Daddy
Tom did not screw me out of the company
he gave me every opportunity to jump in
at the ground floor and I said no not
because I thought it was a bad idea but
because and this is very important
really didn't care about what was
happening so why exactly did you lie
when I asked you what had happened daddy
daddy well I lie to you all the time all
those math camps I said I went to I
don't even know what A math Camp is so
all those postcards that you sent me all
those trophies that you'd won trophies I
bought
I also have something to say
I have done nothing wrong
ever in my life I know this
and I love you I love you too daddy
mommy please my money Dr saberstein your
son is my best friend he's like a
brother to me but he's a disaster and
your daughter seriously needs to be
locked up in some sort of insane asylum
on an island oh in space
have been huge disappoint
come on you love us tell me you love us
and then admit this guy looks like
Beaker from The Muppets
but seriously what are we doing here
now you know the truth will you back off
no I will not stop Yes this all started
his Vengeance for my children but the
company is making money now why would I
back off just because these nincompoops
lie to me all the time no I'm not gonna
back off I'm gonna continue and I'm
gonna Crush you
all right you too are you in for dinner
tomorrow night yes
you know what I love
jello shot
[Applause]
I have an amazing investment idea for
you condoms with pictures on there good
smart I think made my decision take care
welcome Mr saperstein thank you so much
I will just show you do your cubicle I
can't I bet it's a big one huh Barney
the uh temp agency said that you are
fluent with QuickBooks Pro correct all
right yeah we should cover that you see
my resume might not actually be accurate
right so I have no idea what you're
talking about don't know what QuickBooks
are
you don't have any accounting experience
no no Barney come on but you don't have
to be an accountant to know that this
girl is a 10. yeah what up Diaz you come
here often to my job oh he's gonna
meltdown or also shut it is this the new
temp who's supposed to help me with the
spreadsheets I want to talk about
spreading your sheets when we go back to
my place and I will rock yours you're
fired
and so I just go out the same way I came
in
hold up I will do John Mayer again
Danny someone said a fire in your car
because you took too long and I got
bored
oh no no there's no money oh my bad no
problem oh that's fine um I'll just
destroy this office
Ben give her some money it's easier
Tommy T you just missed the craziest of
crazies clubs girls dancing naked mom
argument police fleeing the seed
s are coming here crashing on your
homeless